- [Interviewer] All right, Ryley.
Ryley, here are you from
originally, where'd you grow up?
- I was born in Renton, Washington,
about 20 minutes outside of Seattle.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
And tell me about your family.
- My family, my mom was divorced once,
and then remarried to my dad.
I have two step siblings
a brother and sister,
and a full sister, I'm the
youngest of all of them.
- [Interviewer] Okay. And
how was your childhood?
- My childhood was like very
similar to everyone else's.
My parents tried, they put me in sports.
The one thing for me is like,
I wasn't allowed to have friends over.
I didn't have a, like a normal
childhood in that aspect.
Didn't have many friends,
lived down the woods,
didn't see a lot of people.
There wasn't a huge like
population in my hometown
or at my high school.
But I spent a lot of time
with probably my sister,
and one of my really good
friends and playing sports.
- [Interviewer] So, pretty nice childhood
except for a little isolation.
- As I got older, eight,
nine, 10 closer to my teens,
I started to realize my dad was,
what I now know as an alcoholic,
and it was getting
really bad at that time.
He wasn't around as
much, he was only around
if it was to force me to
play some kind of sport
that he wanted me to play, or control me
in whatever he wanted to do.
And, so it was kinda weird in that aspect.
- [Interviewer] Any abuse
or anything like that?
- Yeah. Well, of course, yeah.
Like I said, I wasn't
allowed to have friends over,
didn't understand that,
so I asked him why.
Like 10, I asked my mom
and my mom would be like,
"It's just your dad's rules,"
and one time I was like,
"Hey, like why am I not
allowed to have friends over?"
And he just, "Don't ask me
again why you're not allowed
"to have people over, I don't
like my stuff being stolen
"or I don't like to have to
watch out for one of you,
"I would have to look after two of you."
And I asked him again, he
fucking, he hit me and he said,
"Shut up, don't ask me again."
(laughing)
And, so I didn't ask him again (laughing).
Shit like that, yeah.
He would, I was physically,
mostly verbally abused by him.
- [Interviewer] And you
left home at what age?
- As soon as I could at 18.
- [Interviewer] 18, and where'd you go?
- I moved in to my buddy Connor's house,
my buddy Connor, we went
to high school together,
me and a couple other
friends we moved in with him
after his dad was hit and killed
by a inebriated driver
from our school actually.
It was pretty crazy. It was crazy.
- [Interviewer] And then drugs
came into the picture for you
at what point?
- Then.
- Right then?
- Right then.
- Yeah.
- It was just, you know,
partying, weed, fun, parties
up until I graduated.
Actually looking back
on that graduation day,
I'd gotten pretty fucked up, drunk,
pretty drunk and took some pills that day,
and with everyone from graduation.
Like, that's not normal,
not everyone did that,
and I was nodding out during graduation.
And of course I'd smoke
weed, and I was hoping
my parents wouldn't notice.
That's not normal, you know what I mean?
So, 18, 19 is when that
started, I started with pills.
I was always able to
set pills down though,
and I watched my buddy
Connor who I moved in with,
that was the first time I realized that
there was a thing called withdrawal.
It was the first time I was shown
what that was, was cause he,
withdrawal, and he was like,
"I can't do this anymore."
He sat in withdrawed on
his couch, smoked weed,
and went through a week of hell by himself
and I was like, "Hmm,
like, I really don't wanna
"touch that shit again man
if that's what it does."
It was crazy.
(gulping)
- [Interviewer] So, where
did the drug situation go
from there for you?
- So.
- Once I turned 19, I
started experimenting
with a lot of drugs.
Made a really good
friend, his name was Noah,
moved from Florida.
We all know Florida is not the best place.
A lot of people there have
been to rehab many times,
there's a lot of rehabs there,
there's a lot of different drugs there.
So, I started experimenting
with pretty much
every single drug there is.
I got back into doing a little
bit of pills, Percosets,
and one day we were looking for him,
and he was like, "Just can't find him man,
"I just can't find him."
And I couldn't find him
either and I was like,
"Shit, man that sucks."
And he was like, "But I do know
where to find like heroin,"
and I was like, "What's that?"
And he was like, "It's
a lot better than pills,
"I think you'll like it,"
and I was like, "Well,
"we might as well, like how much is it?"
He was like "10 bucks"
and I was like, "What!"
We'd been spending 30 man (laughing).
Let's go get it.
We picked it up and,
I remember I took two or three hits of it
off of a foil.
And I was at the donut
shop in Maple Valley,
and I fell asleep or I nodded
out for three, four hours.
And I remember after the
first hit man, it was like,
this is what I was
waiting for my whole life.
This is, I feel fucking
right, I feel like I fit in,
like, this is what I've been looking for.
- I remember that line.
- Yeah.
Yeah, I knew I was fucked, I
knew it, and like, I knew it.
I was like, this isn't
good, but like I'm willing
to let everything go
for this drug right now.
I knew shit was gonna go south from there.
- So that was 19?
- Yeah.
- And how old are you today?
- I'm 26,
I turned 26 last week.
- [Interviewer] 26.
Have you been using it ever since?
- Well, no.
I mean, I've had periods
of sobriety briefly.
The most I've ever had was seven months.
- [Interviewer] Really, how'd you do that?
- Oh Lord, I'm not sure
. Obviously working at a
program, going to meetings,
having a sponsor, you know what I mean?
The cliche stuff, works.
I had a kid on the way,
and my baby's mom,
we just recently broke up
three months ago or so,
she was clean at the time as well.
And I thought it was time
to bottle down there,
and like, it wasn't enough, you know?
And so that's how I did that then.
Treatment, initially
program and fellowship
kept me clean, but the
depression and the bipolar
that I also have, it's been hard.
I don't know, it's hard.
I can't seem to maintain
any type of positive sobriety, and.
It's, I've been to some fucking
bad places 'cause of this,
you know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- Places I never thought I would go,
coming from just a little rural town
called the Ravensdale, Washington,
being a little country boy
wheeling with my friends every day,
to a full blown heroin addict
in fucking LA and Skid Row.
- [Interviewer] This is
the worst part of that.
- It's so easy to score here
though, it's just easy for me,
you know what I mean?
- What do you do for money now?
- Lately it's been (laughing).
Who has access to (indistinct) (laughing).
I don't exactly wanna say it.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
I mean, a lot of people, a
lot of guys will do boosting,
stealing.
- No,
I don't steal necessarily.
I might partake in fraudulent things.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, you
don't need to get into details.
- And, financially,
sometimes I'm doing really
well, but when I'm not,
I'm really not, I have nothing,
and it's really hard for
me to make any money.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- There's always like recycling
if I'm really fucking low,
I need to do something just
to make a couple bucks.
- [Interviewer] Right.
- But normally people have my back,
I mean, they're one step
ahead, and they have
financial means and ways,
usually fraudulently.
And, I used to steal,
can't do it anymore.
I would steal from my family,
steal for my girlfriends,
steal from myself, stores.
Stupid.
- Yeah.
What do you think most people
don't realize about addiction?
(laughing)
- Biggest one for me.
(clearing throat)
My baby's mom's family
has a huge resentment,
and they're like, "How can
you do all these things?"
I've stolen from them,
you know what I mean?
And I've done some pretty poor things
to my baby's mom, or rather
I've done things that I'm not
proud of, and she didn't like,
and her family knows,
you know what I mean?
And they're like, "How can you do that?"
You know I just, I tell them that
I literally do not recognize myself
or that person that made those actions,
because I feel like I wouldn't do them.
It's not who I really am,
and what people don't realize
about addiction is that, if I
don't have a means to get well
or my drug, there's
nothing that's gonna stop
that part of me that
fucking needs that drug,
because it comes before every thing.
It doesn't matter, it
will come before my son,
my family, my wellbeing,
water, food, sleep, sex, anything.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
someone told me recently
it becomes more important than survival.
- Exactly. That is it.
That is survival, and that's
how an addict's brain works,
and it's just fucked (laughing).
- [Interviewer] That's why,
when commenters on my channel
will say, "Oh you just
gotta go to rehab and stop,"
it's like (laughing).
You probably have as much
as, or more common sense
than all the common sense
that's being commented,
but it's not about common sense.
- It's really sad, it's
sad that people think
it's a choice, or.
- A decision.
- They're just like,
"Oh, it's sad they can't
get their lives together."
Well man, it's sad that
you're fucking even commenting
on that and not helping that person,
because if you were in that position,
would you not want help?
It's something like 90%
of addicts don't get help.
I think it's 99% of
addicts don't get help,
and even though I've received help,
it's never been enough for me to continue
and keep a healthy life.
Like, I've been in and
out of treatment 15 times
and hopefully 16 today,
because I really wanna
go to treatment today,
and we're trying to set that up.
Which is weird that if this happened, but,
I've been in and out 16 times
and it's been the fucking `hardest thing
I've ever had to do.
People don't understand how
fucking hard this shit is man.
And no matter what of my
outside circumstances are,
I have a son, baby mama
just got clean with me
fucking four months ago,
she broke up with me and has
a new boyfriend (laughing).
Like, she's clean, that's awesome,
my son, not gonna be
enough to keep me clean.
Like, just because I
have that responsibility,
and just because I want to
doesn't mean like I'm gonna,
I think it's fucked up.
It's fucked.
It's sad.
- [Interviewer] That's a
curse that you can't shake.
You think that you.
- I can man,
it's just, I don't, I gotta
find something that works.
Do you know what I'm saying?
- [Interviewer] Do you think
it's perhaps just your version
of your dad's alcoholism
that you're experiencing?
- Not, I mean, I believe
I'm an alcoholic too,
I'm an alcoholic in an alley.
I do believe.
- [Interviewer] Did
your dad ever get clean?
- No.
I do believe the way he raised me
was not very.
It wasn't a good start
to life and how I should treat people.
He didn't treat me very,
he didn't give me like good values,
he didn't show me shit (laughing).
Unless I fucked up, then he showed me
that I fucked up, you know?
I do believe,
a lot of the negative traits he has,
(inhaling deeply)
like narcissism and.
Whatever, just being mean man (laughing).
And an asshole and fucking.
What is it, when you
say don't do something
and then you go do it?
- Oh, a hypocrite?
- Yeah, you know?
And he hates liars.
I grew up with a dad that hated liars
and, fuck, I turned into a liar quick.
Ever since I was young, like six or seven.
And then it turned into habitual lying,
with my last, with my baby's mom.
And I was in a fantasy world of lies
and she knew that, and one
day I got clean with her
before I came out to
California five months ago
and told her everything, she
didn't know about anything.
She was like, "I know."
And I go, "What? What
do you mean you know?"
She goes, "I know Ryley.
"I've told you every
time that I've asked you
"about these things."
And I was like, "So
you're telling me, like,
"I've been lying to myself
for about seven months, huh?"
She's like, "Yeah, you've been living
"in some kind of fantasy
world, lying to yourself,
"lying to me and believing those lies.
"Nobody else has."
And I was just, that was crazy, you know,
that I didn't think I was as bad
as anybody else in this thing.
'Cause coming from treatment,
like you see other people,
I didn't think I was
as bad or gone as far.
I wasn't in denial still,
I have a problem, right?
But I was man.
I had a problem with bipolar,
and I didn't understand
that I used people,
places and things to make me feel better.
And it went in cycles
and I would lie to myself
that everyone else believed
my lies (giggling).
It is horrible, and you know,
I lost a great relationship
and my son to CPS,
and then we're fighting
for custody back right now.
So, it was a bummer to
have her leave, you know?
But (chuckling).
Sorry.
- It's okay.
You're still young yet.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] You have
a long future ahead of you
that you can straighten out,
but I'm not saying it's easy.
- No, it's not.
But now I'm in a position where I'm alone,
and I'm forced to look at me.
I just gotta fucking
do it one more time, you know what I mean?
It's all I gotta do it,
it's just fucking do it
one more time.
Give it everything I have because...
(snuffling)
I don't wanna live out here
homeless, you know what I mean?
People may think that, like
it's a choice (laughing).
No, it's the worst thing man.
I don't like it out here at all.
It's just hard, you know, it's hard.
- It's a horrible way to live.
- Yeah, I mean (laughing).
I'd rather be back in Washington
with my baby's mom and,
not single, with a child, you know,
that I can't see now,
and owning our house.
I don't want to live on the street
away from those things, you know.
But that's how hard this shit is.
You know. It's crazy.
- [Interviewer] All right,
Ryley, thank you so much
for sharing your story.
- You're welcome.
- Good luck.
- Thank you.